[Música]
pues después de las noticias Ya llega el
momento de hablar de salud aquí en
directo a América de France 24 para ello
contamos un día más con nuestra
compañera Natalia plazas bienvenida
Buenos días Rodrigo buenos días Natalia
vamos a empezar hablando de la gripe
aviar Que quizás empieza a preocupar un
poco porque se reportó la primera Muerte
en humanos por esta enfermedad sí
Rodrigo la reportó justamente ayer
miércoles la ums fue una mujer que se
había contagiado con un tipo de Sub
variante las variantes h3n8 es la
tercera persona que se contagia con esta
sub variante todas las personas que se
han contagiado con ellas se han
detectado también en China la mujer
había sido hospitalizada a principios
del mes pasado y falleció también A
mediados de marzo de acuerdo al reporte
que hizo ayer miércoles la OMS las
infecciones esporádicas en personas con
gripe aviar recordemos Rodrigo que son
comunes en China donde también hay
grandes poblaciones de aves de corral y
también muchas personas en contacto con
ellas las personas que las cuidan por el
momento la OMS ha querido relativizar
esta noticia y ha dicho que considera
que es poco probable que se produzca una
amplia propagación entre la población
veamos
según la información disponible parece
que este virus no tiene la capacidad de
propagarse fácilmente de persona a
persona y por lo tanto el riesgo de que
se propague entre Humanos a nivel
nacional regional e internacional se
considera bajo sin embargo debido a la
naturaleza en constante evolución de los
virus de influenza la OMS enfatiza la
importancia de la vigilancia global para
detectar cambios virológicos
epidemiológicos y clínicos asociados con
los virus de influenza bueno Natalia
pues ante las preocupaciones Nada mejor
que escuchar a la Organización Mundial
de la Salud hay que tener muy en cuenta
que además nos han ayudado mucho durante
este periodo del Kobe 19 vamos a cambiar
de tema y nos vamos hasta California
allí las autoridades parece que han
puesto en marcha un curioso plan para
luchar contra la epidemia esta vez de
sobredosis que afecta al país de acuerdo
Rodrigo concretamente se lleva a cabo en
el condado de marine en el norte de San
Francisco allí las autoridades lidian
con lo que llaman una epidemia de drogas
y sobredosis se trata este curioso plan
como bien lo has dicho de una estrategia
para rastrear sustancias como el
fentanilo las metanfetaminas y la
cocaína entre otras sustancias altamente
adictivas y lo hacen analizando muestras
de aguas residuales una técnica que
comenzaron a utilizar al principio de la
pandemia para rastrear el virus del
covid 19 el sars así describe la
situación en el condado de marine uno de
los médicos especialistas del Condado
esto es importante porque se trata de
una crisis de salud pública perdemos un
residente cada cinco días en el condado
de marine el riesgo de morir por una
sobredosis en el condado de Marvin fue
10 veces mayor que el riesgo de morir
por covid 19 para cualquier persona
menor de 60 años el año pasado
bueno Y es que estos planes llegan en un
momento no sé si decir crítico pero
desde luego muy preocupante en Estados
Unidos por el aumento de las muertes en
el país
Sí muy preocupante como bien lo dices y
este tipo de planes lo que hace es
ayudar a las autoridades a prepararse un
poco y a poder tomar medidas de
respuesta y sobre todo de prevención una
de estas medidas es por ejemplo la
distribución de algunos fármacos que
revierten en una situación de urgencia
en una situación ya extrema por ejemplo
los efectos de una sobredosis y de esta
manera también evitan que se produzcan
más muertes hemos preparado un gráfico
en el que podemos ver también el impacto
de las drogas en el condado y en el país
como podemos ver ha habido un incremento
que podríamos Llamar casi que dramático
en este condado en 2018 ya había train
ya hubo 30 muertas 30 muertes por
sobredosis y esas aumentaron a 6 cinco
en 2021 el doble para 2022 cabe Resaltar
que todavía no están los datos completos
por ello también la cifra disminuyó un
poco a nivel nacional pues entendemos
que es una problemática de Escala
Nacional los casos también han ido en
aumento en los últimos 20 años
prácticamente bueno sean más que
cuadruplicado en como vemos a finales
del 2000 a principios del 2000 había
20.000 casos y en 2021 ya nos fuimos
hasta
106 mil casos en total es un incremento
como podemos ver Rodrigo completamente
dramático desde luego que sí 106.000
personas más de 106.000 personas en un
año es muchísimo venía estos días
escuchando un podcast además que hablaba
que muchas de estas personas que
entraron a ser dependientes del
fentanilo lo hicieron Después de algunas
operaciones en hospitales de Estados
Unidos porque era una droga legal era un
fármaco que empieza a mucho en el país
Natalia terminamos con otra polémica El
fabricante de cigarrillos electrónicos
Jules deberá pagar
462 millones de dólares tras una demanda
de seis estados del país por vender sus
productos a menores de edad Rodrigo es
una noticia digamos impactante y lo
grave de esta noticia es que no es el
primer acuerdo al que llega El
fabricante ya ha habido otros acuerdos
con al menos 40 estados en el país por
más de mil millones de dólares y todos
por la misma causa que es vender
productos altamente adictivos a menores
de edad la fda en este sentido alertó el
año pasado de que el uso de cigarrillos
electrónicos entre la población
adolescente representa un grave riesgo
para la salud nacional cabe recordar
también Rodrigo que las sustancias
adictivas como la nicotina pueden causar
daños en el cerebro y concretamente
afectan a la población adolescente ya
que afectan su atención su capacidad de
aprender también su estado de ánimo y su
conducta y es por ello que es tan
importante
informar sobre los efectos que tiene el
consumo de este tipo de aparatos
electrónicos Natalia también preocupante
siempre las adicciones entre los menores
de edad Muchas gracias por estar aquí
hoy vamos a ir con un repaso también a
la que ha sido la primera entrevista de
nuestra invitada del día de nuevo
gracias Natalia Gracias Rodrigo